il avait connu roosevelt staline
churchill de gaulle tito est à paris
raymond barre pour le budget 78 les prix
n'augmenteront pas de plus de 6%
le conseil des ministres confirme pas ce
déplafonnement de la sécurité sociale
des cadrans 78 étrange cure
d'amaigrissement près de reims trois
morts israël oui à genève non à l'ol
paie après l'accord carter bayane
mais messieurs bonsoir 21 coups de canon
quatre mirage f1 pour escorter la liant
yougoslave depuis la frontière le
président république touly min soo
presque le maréchal tito a eu vraiment
droit au plus qu'en égard à son arrivée
cet après midi à paris voilà plus de
vingt ans que josip broz tito ne s'était
rendu en france pour une visite
officielle valéry giscard d'estaing
avait dit de son côté à belgrade
il y à peine un an et avait semblé très
impressionné par les jugements de ce
grande histoire ce qui explique
peut-être que les deux hommes se soient
revues si vite
à 85 ans le maréchal tito semble se
porter comme un charme c'est la première
impression que l'on ressent en regardant
le chef de l'état yougoslave passe en
revue les troupes venues le saluer à son
arrivée en france le dernier des grands
chefs d'état historique de la dernière
guerre mondiale encore en vie continue
par la france à grande tournée commencée
à moscou et à pékin devant lisbonne et
washington
inventeur du non alignement de la
neutralité entre les deux blocs pitot ne
contrôle en france qu'un accueil
chaleureux dans les thèses des deux pays
sur une grands problèmes mondiaux sont
souvent parallèles
non
rien n'est plus indispensable que de
réunir les efforts de tous ceux qui sont
prêts à agir en faveur des deux causes
qui domine la nécessité de notre temps
la détente et la coopération entre les
nations
audace dans les mots ces machins
répondants presque en écho au président
français la maraîchère à tout dire à nos
deux boeufs et sont avant tout jaloux de
leur indépendance et nos deux pays ont
des vues pratiquement semblable sur les
grands problèmes internationaux
après l'accueil premier des trois têtes
à tête prévu durant lesquelles le
maréchal tito exposera à monsieur
giscard d'estaing les problèmes actuels
de son pays problèmes économiques la
france est le troisième fournisseur
occidental a eu sa vie mais nos achats
sont de loin inférieurs à nos vents et
puis bien sûr problème politique le
maréchal pense à l'avenir lui disparu
qu'adviendra-t-il de la neutralité
yougoslave qui ne manquera pas d'être
attaquée du dehors mais aussi de
l'intérieur c'était à fédéral ne
comprend pas moins de six républiques
aussi différentes les unes que les
autres
le personnage légendaire disparu que se
passera-t-il c'est ce que tito et s'est
lui même de prévoir et d'expliquer au
cours de cette grande tournée le budget
suite c'est donc à la tribune de
l'assemblée que raymond barre cet après
midi est venu défendre son projet pour
78 essentiel des chiffres nous les
connaissons des yeah yeah et et nous les
avons commenté mais aujourd'hui premier
ministre à à signer sa conception de la
politique des salaires idées-forces le
maintien toujours assez strict du
pouvoir d'achat écoutez la possibilité
d'une progression du pouvoir d'achat
sera examinée avant la fin de l'année
compte tenu de l'évolution de la
situation économique d'ensemble et
notamment de l'évolution des prix le
gouvernement recommande à cet égard que
cette progression éventuelle de pouvoir
d'achat concerne les seules
rémunérations dont le monde
monde mensuel ne dépasse pas 18 mille
francs au delà de ce montant les
rémunérations ne devrait pas progresser
du début à la fin de l'année plus vite
que les prix à la consommation
enfin dans les cas relativement peu
nombreux mais plus nombreux qu'on pense
ou les rémunération mensuelle dépasse 30
mille francs
celles ci devraient rester stables en
valeur nominale
comme en 1977
un effort particulier d'accroissement du
pouvoir d'achat sera effectué en faveur
des travailleurs au smic des familles
des personnes âgées et des travailleurs
manuels maintenir avec notre ministre a
annoncé une politique ne montrent assez
semblable celle qui est donnée cette
année
si l'ambiance est tout à fait la même
politique effectivement c'est frappant
en matière de rémunération puisque vous
l'avez vu pour le premier ministre
l'idée est toujours de régler la hausse
des salaires sur la hausse des prix
globalement le maintien du pouvoir
d'achat n'est pas plus ce qui est encore
plus frappant c'est quand on voit le
nouvel objectif du premier ministre en
matière de prix vous avez que cette
année en 77 l'objectif était de limiter
la hausse des prix à six et demi pour
cent mais bien pour 78 l'objectif sera
encore abc il faut limiter la hausse des
prix à 6%
l'effort pour lutter contre l'inflation
et non plus affirmer que jamais
d'ailleurs les contrôles pour les
entreprises pour les commerçants tout ce
dispositif seront maintenus alors pas
uniquement le maintien de politiques
dans le domaine des primes et dans tous
les autres domaines
oui un exemple les économies d'énergie
vous savez que cette année il y avait un
plafond pour les achats de produits
pétroliers produits énergétiques à
l'étranger ils étaient 55 milliards de
francs bien l'année prochaine il sera à
peine augmenté 58 milliards de francs et
puis enfin à propos de l'énergie
monsieur bart a précisé que la politique
nucléaire de la france serait poursuivi
je crois que c'est important retenir
donc pour l'ensemble des nouvelles
dispositions que nous avons appris
aujourd'hui un ensemble à l'issue duquel
le premier ministre a essayé de dégager
disons la philosophie générale de son
budget la france aura cette année en
dépit de
toutes ces difficultés un taux de
croissance qui ne se compare pas de
façon défavorable à celui de beaucoup
d'autres pays et notamment de notre
puissant voisin l'allemagne fédérale
notre pays a pu retrouver une certaine
marge de manoeuvre
mais les perspectives internationales
aussi bien que les problèmes économiques
intérieurs continuent et continueront à
nous imposer le respect de certaines
disciplines et la poursuite de l'effort
c'est dans cet esprit que le
gouvernement a fixé les orientations de
la politique économique et sociale pour
1978 il n'a pas limité son horizon au
seul premier - de 1978 qui nous sépare
des échéances électorales pourquoi parce
qu'il est le gouvernement il est clair
en effet qu'aucun gouvernement sauf s'il
est prêt à l'aventuré ne pourrait
ignorer au cours de l'année prochaine
les limites que les exigences et les
contraintes de la situation nationale et
internationale fixe nos désirs parfois
exprimées de nouveauté ou d'originalité
voilà des propos qui ne sont plus
directement économique et j'imagine
daniel brême que ce discours a dû être
commentée dans les couloirs du palais
bourbon alors comment est ce qu'il a été
reçu par les députés eh bien d'abord un
bon point décerné par monsieur flornoy
le premier a perdu son ton professoral
de l'an dernier monsieur salé trouve lui
que monsieur bart est une sorte de
churchill de l'économie sa politique est
sérieuse est faite de rigueur pour les
giscardiens comme monsieur hamel où
monsieur chine où il est bon de répéter
toujours la même chose afin de faire
entendre la vérité aux français à savoir
que seule une monnaie saine et un
commerce extérieur bonne santé peuvent
rétablir l'emploi
enfin pour monsieur de lallaing
rpr sûr qu'il l'a surtout frapper il n'a
pas été le seul c'est que monsieur bart
a dit un certain nombre de choses et
s'est montrée assuré d'être encore là en
juillet 78 alors ça c'est pour la
majorité du côté de l'opposition
maintenant eh bien monsieur va longer
communistes trouvent je cite que
monsieur barak eut le culot phénoménal
car il prône l'austérité face à une
situation dramatique pour les
travailleurs monsieur jean pierre cot et
boulloche pour les socialistes trouvent
la bonne conscience du premier ministre
consternante
mais tandis que plusieurs socialistes
ont noté jolie noter aussi que le
premier ministre et il avoue n'avait
l'air assez satisfait n'avait pas
attaqué l'opposition monsieur de prémont
rpr lui tout en considérant que monsieur
var s'était comporté comme un bon
ministre des finances a regretté lui que
justement monsieur barre n'ait pas mis
son discours dans un cadre plus
politique vous voyez il est difficile de
faire plaisir à tout le monde
la suite du débat dans les jours à venir
pour en revenir au prix maintenant le
gouvernement n'a pas attendu 78% prendre
quelques hausses abusives
essentiellement du côté de
l'alimentation comité des prix s'est
réuni cet après midi pour entériner des
mesures que jean-claude lalique a décidé
de nous présenter à l'aide d'un panier
de la ménagère ainsi modernisé trop de
prix ont dérapé alors une nouvelle fois
le comité national des prix s'est fâché
premiers accusés c'est un vieil habitué
le café nous vous l'avons déjà dit dès
lundi il devrait baisser de 10%
autre spécialiste du dérapage des prix
des légumes et notamment aujourd'hui les
carottes les oignons qui sont
anormalement cher pour la saison le
comité national des prix a donc décidé
de bloquer les marges relative les
commerçants en appliquant un coefficient
multiplicateur de 1,5 c'est un peu
compliqué mais cela veut dire que le
commerçant qui achètera ses carottes
roual de francs devra les vendre de
francs x 1,5 c'est à dire au maximum 3
franck kg et puis le comité des prix
s'est aussi préoccupé du 20 mai du vin
vendu chez les restaurateurs
il a considéré que les marges pratiqués
par les restaurateurs étaient
anormalement élevé supérieur à 3% il est
là donc réduite d'un demi point qu'en
fin mais ce n'est peut-être pas une
bonne nouvelle pour les consommateurs
le comité national des prix à autoriser
les bouchers et les charcutiers à
augmenter leurs marges mais selon la
direction des prix cela ne devrait pas
se traduire par une hausse pour les
consommateurs car parallèlement les
cours du boeuf et du porc sont en baisse
à la production théoriquement mais les
et les consommateurs savent par
expérience que la théorie et la logique
sont rarement de leur côté et puis
dernière décision du comité des prix le
fioul domestique augmentera de 2,7
centimes par litre à partir de dimanche
troisième train de décisions elles nous
viennent cette fois du conseil des
ministres d'aujourd'hui elle concerne
les cadres les cadres toujours inquiet
dès lors que des hauts fonctionnaires se
mettent à jeter les grandes lignes d'un
budget quelconque mais des cadres qui ce
soir laurence graff fin je crois ont
tout lu tout réseau en tout cas d'être
satisfait il faut dire qu'on leur a
donné presque tout ce qu'ils demandaient
oui alors il ya toute une série de
mesures dont je ne donnerai que
quelques-unes la première ils ont calé
financière touche le plafond des
cotisations de sécurité sociale est ce
qui l'intéresse saute alors ce plafond
c'est la limite du clr qui est prise en
compte pour les cotisations de sécurité
sociale
actuellement il est de 3600 10 francs
bien que quelqu'un qui gagne 3620 aux
4000 ou 5000 francs celle généralement à
cadres ne paient des cotisations du
régime général que dans la limite de
trois mille six cent dix francs et tous
les ans le plafond est modifié en tenant
compte de l'évolution des salaires et
c'est le mode de calcul de cette
évolution qui va être changée à la fin
de cette année et ça permettra sans
doute une augmentation moins rapide du
plafond en général calculée sur
l'évolution des salaires des ouvriers
dans l'art théâtral plus largement du
salaire des cadres que l'or la deuxième
mesure c'est que le gouvernement s'est
engagé à ne pas déplacer lire à
maintenir le plafond en 1978 d'accord
alors troisième type de mesure
maintenant des mesures de participation
alors oui des mesures pour associer les
cadres plus particulièrement à la
gestion de l'entreprise
il ya d'abord un projet de loi qui
créerait des structures de concertation
pour les cas dans les entreprises et
puis un deuxième projet beaucoup plus
imprécis qui permettrait au cac
d'accueillir des axes
dans l'entreprise ou qui leur
permettraient éventuellement d'être
représenté au conseil d'administration
le conseil de surveillance alors c'est
monsieur de l'ouvrier qui a été chargée
d'étudier ce projet donc pour leur
permettre de participer davantage à la
vie d'entreprise voient en effet de quoi
soulager les cadres certains contestent
la philosophie ces mesures nous le
verrons tout à l'heure mais le présent
la plus grosse organisation la cgc ne
cachait pas sa satisfaction tout à
l'heure nous pouvons déclarer que nous
sommes très satisfaits de ce changement
et de l'ouverture par le gouvernement
vis-à-vis des cadres dandy longtemps
assuré la place non seulement par
l'entreprise mais aussi la société est
ce que ces mesures cette satisfaction de
votre part entraîneront des prises de
positions préélectorale nous demeurons
totalement à des gains indépendant de
toute prise de position politique
quand nous sommes mécontents nous lisons
quand nous sommes satisfaits nous le
disent aussi
alors chiche à portishead i stem et les
organisations syndicales celles qui sont
liées aux grandes centrales syndicales
le sont beaucoup moins
parce qu'ils estiment que les structures
de concertation seront des structures
parallèles dans l'entreprise et que
l'ensemble des mesures prises
aujourd'hui tendrait à dissocier voir à
opposer les cadres et les autres
salariés
mais ça c'est le cas donc des
fédérations lié à soual si j'étais sous
la cfdt
essentiellement pour en terminer avec
les affaires sociales cette confirmation
il n'y aura pas de grève à la sncf ce
week-end les agents de conduite autonome
annuler leur mot d'ordre après la
signature d'un accord salarial pour 77
quatre fédérations ont signé andré
bergeron on s'en est félicitée pour
force ouvrière en faisant le compte des
différents accords enregistrée dans le
secteur public la sncf
le dr les charbonnages la ratp et puis
là c est à dire les tabacs et des
allumettes
du côté des fonctionnaires en revanche
deux semaines d'action dans le mois à
venir
à l'appel de six fédérations la
politique maintenant quelques flashs de
déclaration hier soir à grenoble celle
de jacques chirac qui poursuit son tour
de france en s'en prenant à françois
mitterrand c'est le socialisme français
tout entier qui l'a jeté dans la
corbeille à 10
président du rpr et puis celle de
françois mitterrand toujours à grenoble
qui a critiqué le pouvoir des préfets et
des énarques et qui a demandé un délai
de réflexion et d'information pour
superphénix le gouvernement par la
bouche de rené monory s'est déclaré
surpris par cette proposition de
moratoire
cela ressemble à un faux semblants a dit
le ministre la renaissance d'un parti
politique de jeunes qui existent déjà
qui vous voyez ne manque pas d'humour
sous le nom de gsl génération sociale et
libérale et bien les jeunes giscardiens
vont s'appeler désormais autrement
autrement c'est le nom de leur nouveau
mouvement et cela va d'ailleurs posé
quelques problèmes puisque une revue qui
n'a aucun rapport avec les jeunes
giscardiens s'appelait déjà comme ça
alors la justice va trancher
particularité de ce nouveau mouvement
pas de président une direction
collégiale de neuf membres que vous avez
vu est une action qui se veut
dépolitisée enfin la mort ce matin d'un
membre du conseil constitutionnel henri
rey ancien ministre toute sa vie fidèle
au gaullisme l'étranger maintenant avec
tout d'abord le proche-orient cinq
heures de négociations pas moins pour
que le cabinet israélien accepte à
l'unanimité
le document signé à washington entre le
président carter et le général moshe
bayane en principe
israël se rendra à genève à condition
que l'ol paie il faut pas représenté la
réaction des palestiniens ne s'est pas
fait attendre
un de ses responsables a affirmé à new
york
il ne peut y avoir de paix sans les
palestiniens et pas de palestiniens sans
logis
cependant au delà de ses positions très
dures il semble que chacun des camps ce
désir s'asseoir à la table de la
conférence de genève vous rappelle que
ce soir à 20h30
notre magazine question de temps
consacrera une émission exceptionnelle à
ce sujet avec de très bons reportages à
l'appui vous le verrez quatre ans après
la fin de la guerre d'octobre
ce soir donc 20h30 un peu plus bas sur
la carte du monde nord-yémen nord-yémen
habitués à une longue tradition de
violence dès hier c'est le chef de
l'état et son beau frère qui ont été
assassinés voilà donc à nouveau toute
cette région du monde en face de
djibouti déstabiliser verra ce bac va
vous expliquer pourquoi lui qui avait
rencontré cet été le président norgay
minutes dans son palais à l'endroit même
où on l'a tué hier le président hamdi
s'entourer pourtant aux mesures de
sécurité importantes c'est dans son
village natal perché sur un piton
rocheux à quelques kilomètres de la
capitale qui nous avait expliqué sa
politique de non alignement dans le
domaine de la politique extérieure notre
position est très claire nous voulons
garder l'amitié de tous nos amis et
coopérer avec tous nos frères arabes
mais nous devenons la première place à
l'arabie saoudite qui continue à aider
le peuple et le gouvernement est mineur
soit la manière mais est ce que le
président pense que cette région peut
devenir un point chaud du monde dans les
prochaines heures
nous espérons que non
face à djibouti avec une large façade
maritime dans le bab el mandeb la sortie
de la mer rouge vers l'océan indien au
yémen occupe une position stratégique
capitale le régime modéré pro occidental
du président hamdi est l une des cartes
de la france dans cette région après son
voyage à paris des liens d'amitié de
coopération et 3 s'était nouée entre le
yemen
et la france disparu personne ne sait
encore quelle sera la politique suivie
par ses successeurs
resteront-ils pro occidentaux où seront
ils tentés par le régime voisin le yémen
d'aden lui profondément prosoviétique
kaos croissant restaurant en prison sa
demande de mise en liberté provisoire a
été rejetée aujourd'hui mais ça ne
préjuge pas de la décision des autorités
françaises quant à une extradition ou
non
en allemagne ce qui me vient l'étrange
affaire qu'ont découverte aujourd'hui
nos reporters cela se passe dans une
petit village de l'aube dans un petit
village qui s'appelle a réuni là ne les
policiers sur plainte déposée au parquet
trois ont perquisitionné ce matin un
petit hôtel de la localité à l'hôtel où
l'on pratique l'hygiénisme et je dois
avouer qu'avant que philippe gassot
devant parle je ne sais pas ce que
c'était en gros une cure
d'amaigrissement volontaire mais dans de
bien curieuses conditions ya quatre ans
on s'était déjà ému dans le village un
pensionnaire de l'hôtel était mort plus
tard un autre client passer par
l'établissement lui aussi moore est
bizarrement en angleterre et tout
récemment un troisième décédées en
suisse il ne pesait plus que 29 kg alors
c'en était trop et le parquet ouvre une
information depuis 1974 donc trois
personnes sont mortes après avoir suivi
une cure dans l'étrange hôtel de rigny
une plainte a été déposée la semaine
dernière c'est ce qui a décidé les
policiers à investir la maison ce matin
le médecin et le directeur ont été
déférés au parquet de troyes et ça n'est
pas une surprise
salou est un genre de siècle ceux qui
viennent je ne critique pas mais ils
savent bien à quoi il s'expose un faut
dire le mot il peut alors là dedans moi
qui me le demandent quelque chose lors
du mois un jeu vous avez pris votre vous
avez fait votre testament ou en devenir
qu'est ce qu'on dit cela dans le village
est ici sans tout ce dont elles ont la
vue là-dessus c'est un drôle de zigue
aux moeurs qu'est ce que vous pensez des
malades qui viennent là vous en avez vu
quelques-uns sont des fanatiques
monsieur exactement 1 exactement et ce
qu'ils mangeaient bariki manger quand
même parfois des choses étranges des bus
trams de la betterave blanche
c'est certainement de +3 à sucre dont on
dit qu'il mangeait des feuilletés petra
pourtant les clients semblent satisfaits
et oui c'est comme ça si on veut avoir
la peau de quelqu'un on met tout le
paquet on a à vendre toutes sortes de
choses on trouve toujours des moyens y
avait quelqu'un est un escroc ou qui l'a
assassiné
n'est ce pas parce que nous ici nous
faisons une cure de jeunes une ou deux
fois il ya eu un il est arrivé un
accident que quelqu'un soit soit mort
après après avoir terminé la cure mais
mourir tout le monde meurt il paraîtrait
que des clients sont morts des suites de
la cure si vous avez eu connaissance de
cela machin trop vous ne sentez pas
responsable en turban ou la vie examiner
oui j'ai eu quand il est entré
celui-ci vous êtes satisfait des
traitements qui vous a été imposée ici
ou que vous avez accepté volontiers mais
pas complètement satisfait parce que le
directeur répond lui aussi aux
accusations
monsieur vous est suspecté d'avoir
indirectement provoqué la mort de
plusieurs personnes qui avaient doit
répondre à cela
le médecin les a vus à l'arrivée et les
avait à la sortie de gien des fiches
médicales pour chacun et ils le laissent
partir quand ils sont en effet partis et
sont tous partis le jeune homme qui est
parti le premier les parties à
l'angleterre par ses propres moyens
voiture un limeur pesant 29 kg quand
même c'est pas beaucoup je ne sais pas
dans quelles conditions éléments je
viens d'apprendre le savait pas du tout
est-ce que vous avez l'impression d'être
un peu responsable grimpant à lire
absolument pas il est parti en bon état
marini donc deux parties sont en
présence la direction et les
pensionnaires les clients qui paient
cher et qui sont contents de le faire
d'eux les curistes qui acceptent de
consommer des feuilles de betteraves à
vaches ou des fanes de radis qui
rapporte gros propriétaires et peut-être
même des ennuis bientôt on n'a pas fini
d'en parler
voilà une affaire dont nous ont
effectivement à reparler un hold-up
meurtrier ce matin à grenoble un mort un
blessé grave chez les gangsters et un
inspecteur blessé également ce matin
quatre hommes armés et masqués pénètrent
dans une banque
impasse en alerte la police sur les
lieux quelques minutes plus tard les
malfaiteurs ouvre alors le feu et blesse
un inspecteur riposte deux gangsters
s'écroule les deux autres s'enfuit ils
seront rattrapés sur les toits d'un
immeuble voisin
une heure plus tard quatre airbus de
plus pour la lufthansa qui transforme en
commandes fermes quatre des six options
qu'elle détenait sur l'appareil et qui
prend cette option supplémentaire avec
nous martin arogno est toujours dans nos
conversations le cancer avec la semaine
du cancer climat oui cette fois ci on va
faire un appel à la population française
dans son ensemble
vous dites semaines je dirais trimestre
parce que tout au long de ces mois qui
viennent on va demander aux français de
participer à des manifestations
sportives de théâtre etc mais aussi
carrément une contribution
ils vont recevoir tous 18 millions de
france de familles françaises vont se
voir cette carte leur demandant de
contribuer pour une somme de 15 francs
minimum à la lutte contre le cancer et
leur demander s'ils veulent recevoir
chez eux un dossier d'information sur le
cancer comme celui
qui leur expliquera un certain nombre de
choses alors on espère obtenir ainsi 30
millions 30 millions pour aider la
recherche car il y à de grands progrès
fait des raisons d'espérer car on l'a
dit la semaine dernière un certain
nombre de cancers peuvent être guéris et
d'autres prévenus sur l'emprunt les
moyens il y aussi beaucoup de raisons de
chercher pour ça il faut de l'argent
oui alors tranquillement c'est beaucoup
mais parfois on se demande un peu ce que
ça va devenir le fait que de faire
pressante qui ont fait poser quelques
questions qu'est ce que ça vous dit oui
alors ce matin au ministère de la santé
il y avait une conférence de presse est
la question a été posée car certains ont
été déçus
alors on leur a bien précisé que
premièrement tous des bénévoles plus
personne n'est payé dans cette campagne
il ya pratiquement pas d' agence de
relations publiques et celles qui
donnent un coup de main le font
bénévolement il faut que ce soit clair
la cour des comptes on voit quelqu'un
qui supervise la totalité de l'opération
l'argent sera donné avant tout à des
bourses de chercheurs et le reste sera
réparti équitablement entre
l'association pour le cancer de
villejuif les centres anticancéreux et
la ligue contre le cancer
je crois qu'il faut signaler que
l'antenne de à sa manière de participer
à cette opération louis xii cancérologue
les plus grands étaient là ce matin pour
soutenir cette campagne
six d'entre eux viendront la semaine
prochaine à 18h40 dont c'est la vie nous
donner des informations très pratique
enfin le football pour terminer
l'irlande et la bulgarie ont fait match
nul 0 à 0 cet après midi à dublin
un match dont les supporters français
attendait le résultat avec impatience
car ces deux nations sont dans le même
groupe que le onze tricolore pour la
qualification à la poule finale du
championnat demande résultat nul donc et
pour les français ce n'est ni bon ni
mauvais
si hollande le tri pourquoi le 16
novembre prochain au parc des princes
pour le dernier match du groupe 5
comptant pour les éliminatoires de la
coupe du monde il faudra absolument que
la france
donc de là bulgarie et cela par
n'importe quel sport tel est le verdict
du match r bulgarie 0 0 disputé cet
après midi à lansdowne road à dublin
match décevant dominé par les irlandais
mais sans beaucoup d'occasions de but
dans 34 jours au parc cela ne sera pas
facile face à une équipe bulgare pour
laquelle un match nul sera suffisent
mais les tricolores le savait déjà et
les trésors platini ray bathenay leurs
camarades ont les moyens de gagner un
match que vous ne verrez même pas en
différé ce soir sur antenne 2 toujours
en raison de nos mêmes problèmes nous
avons promis d'ouvrir ce dossier sur la
place publique vous feront samedi dans
l'émission de jean pierre elkabbach
samedi et demi sur son plateau la
plupart des parties prenantes à ce
dossier
voilà le temps pour terminer aujourd'hui
les températures seront plutôt en hausse
pour demain les spécialistes prévoient
un temps frais le matin avec quelques
éclaircies des pluies isolées tomberont
sur le nord et sur le nord-est le temps
s'éclaircira au cours de la journée
voilà votre dernier rendez-vous avec
l'actualité et à 22h55
sous la baguette de gérard holtz au
revoir à la main